i think i remember we had like there
were like 5 000 scripts with 147 on me
and then they had to make sure that they
were facing out because it'll blow a
hole in you are you nuts
as he was wiring me and just putting the
last piece of electrical tape on he said
you know i've been doing this for 50
years i i've never put this many squibs
on anybody in my life
i said thanks dude i mean that i'm glad
you told me that now i mean there was
glass and wood and stuff flying
everywhere so i had to make sure this
hand was there and this hand was there
people said oh look you were dancing no
i was scared to death
well that's why i can joke about it
because i'm sitting here it was pretty
scary what's the matter with you
i think your brain is going soft with
all that comedy you're playing with that
young girl
never tell anybody outside the family
what you're thinking again
first of all you know it was a fun
character you know i mean he was
pretty volatile and pretty much alive
and unpredictable and that plus the fact
that everything he did was for his
family it was because you know his
sister is his brother his father you
know even though he was a loon i mean he
was violently passionate so it's almost
like you you know you condoned you know
like you know
sonny for you know doing what he did
because it was all for family it was all
out of done for family it was almost
like you know it was excusable
you know and and that sort of love
in this horrible gangster picture
[Music]
[Applause]
the ingredients were terrific i mean you
know we had the val and pacino and
marlin you know so it was fun making it
because i was with friends and i was
with good actors you know
the outcome was unbeknownst to all of us
if one never knows what the public you
know is going to like and except for the
reason for its success
i mean it's very hard to get a picture
that
that the people
and critics you know
like equally i attribute it to
the fact that
francis is
a very aesthetic guy what are you gonna
do
nice college boy yeah they want to get
mixed up in the family business it's one
of my three or four favorites certainly
the most colorful that when i first saw
the picture you know the nation i was so
upset man you know because you know
actors you know you get a little selfish
because you only look at you and go hey
manny
how come he cut out that scene now can
we cut out that thing how come that part
in there i wasn't even gonna go to the
party i was so upset that'll beg me to
call you oh man they cut me out of the
party here coming out of this scene and
call me i hate you francis you know
so i didn't know it was good
i never somebody told me it was good
then i was happy
[Music]
you